welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast i'm your
host hisham azuz and this is another
edition of the early on in recruitment
podcast series where we're sitting down
with people who are early on in their
recruitment career to find out what have
been some of their biggest challenges
how they overcame them
advice that they would give
to people coming into the industry
and
much more so i'm really delighted to be
joined by amber nathan today who worked
for a business called verti talent and
that is actually a recruitment business
that helps entry-level talent into the
recruitment industry so we're going to
talk to amber and nathan about their own
journeys but also they're in a really
unique position to give all of you
listening to this some insight into
yeah what sort of things to expect what
sort of things can we look for when we
are looking to get into the recruitment
industry and yeah just get their take um
on those types of things so amber gonna
come to you first and so where i've been
starting these conversations
is i would love just to hear sort of
your thoughts on
how has recruitment been compared to
what you expected so far
yeah so this is my first recruitment job
i i haven't come from a sales or
recruitment background so i came in very
blind to be honest um very different to
like nate's background so i didn't
really have
too many expectations to be honest um i
knew with our market you know it was
like heavily phone based a lot of it was
inbound i know you had to be like
spinning multiple plates at once but i
think i underestimated
how fast-paced it actually is um you do
need to be able to you know multitask
and be beyond the ball um especially in
a market like ours as well because i
think our market is quite different to a
lot of others so you know we come into
you know applications day in day out and
you know speed is is key um especially
in our markets i think i
i knew it was fast paced i knew you had
to pick up the phone very quickly and be
on it but i think i kind of
underestimated how fast it actually was
uh and obviously you know there's
competitors out there
you know um the candidates might be
applying directly
so you do really
yeah you've got to have that tunnel
vision come in sit down and just
basically hammer through them as soon as
you can really
yeah fair enough
so so nath obviously for you just for
context for people listening obviously
we were just saying so like worked a
recruitment business for two years
unfortunately covered meant that that
sort of had to come to an end you then
got into a sales role but then as you
were saying when you moved back up to
munster like you was uh yeah really keen
to get back into people-facing role and
like the opportunity to get back into
recruitment so obviously you've been a
you've obviously been a vertis now
coming up to uh nearly a year so i guess
what what i'd love to just get your
thoughts on and you can sort of share
what you think you've taken from your
journey with virtus so far even before
but what what skills or experience do
you think recruitment has given you that
maybe you you least expected
yeah it's a conversation with me and i'm
having the other day actually um i think
i we've both come into it sort of
completely differently sometimes i think
um's actually you'd think outside of
looking in it's easier for someone like
myself to come into it but sometimes
coming in as a blank canvas is actually
a massive positive because you've got no
prerequisites you've got no bad habits
from previous roles and you can sort of
just hit the ground running so i almost
had to sort of unlearn before i could
start to learn again when i came into
virtus which is maybe something i wasn't
prepared for came in thinking that you
know all of those experiences that i had
previously would be positive and there
were some where i actually had to
unlearn habits before i could sort of
really kick on so it actually arguably
took me a little bit longer than some of
the other associates here to get to
retcon um but now that i've got there
i'm sort of performing quite well so i
suppose one experience from myself was
that initial phase of coming in that
actually has a blank canvas you can
sometimes hit the ground running a
little bit better i think in terms of a
more sort of positive experience i came
into this having done purely solo roles
before and where it was all about sort
of my own performance i think coming in
now and and being a part of training up
some of the associates as me and number
both kick on towards senior and then
we'll look on to sort of management i
think leadership isn't something i've
ever considered before bertas but i
think being in that sort of 360 role is
now actually something that i'm sort of
striving towards so i suppose that was a
an experience i wasn't necessarily
expecting but one that i've certainly
relished and the opportunity to have
nice and then and then any skills names
that you think like you've developed
professionally personally that maybe you
didn't think from what you'd get from
working in recruitment i'm sure you went
into it going right i'm gonna carry on
my sales skills my people skills but is
that do you feel like it's impacted any
other things that you've maybe been
surprised by sort of just skill wise and
maybe even character wise is you as a
person
i think yeah probably probably what you
pick up on there um lastly about me as a
person i think when you're doing like if
you look at my previous role working in
sales it's very transactional it's
product based so you've got the sales
skills but it's not so much on the
people side of things i think i to give
people my background away from work
obviously moved up to manchester knowing
no one and then step back into
recruitment as well and i think it came
at the perfect time because i think that
relationship building element that
people focus role has probably helped me
massively outside of work because i was
doing quite well in a recruitment role
building relationships with people
didn't know anyone outside the office
and i thought i'd just sort of mirror
that out of the office as well and i
think it's probably made me ten times
more sociable outside of work as well
and it's helped me to build sort of a
social as well as professional network
all at the same time
yeah i love that no yeah good on you
mate that's i think that's a great thing
to share particularly for people yeah
moving into different cities and these
things that can be really daunting right
and you've got to really lean in to
being in those new environments and
being on your own and you have to sort
of put your neck out there right to
speak to people and build those social
things so that that's awesome to hear
that it's helped that i guess i'm sure
both of you speak to people about this
so i'm gonna i'm gonna come to you on
this but i'm sure you may at some point
or i'm sure it's something that you guys
communicate but a very typical sentence
i'd certainly heard it is the look first
in recruitment can be probably your
hardest right so let's let's talk i want
to find out what some of your biggest
challenges have been so am i going to
come to you like looking at your sort of
first year in recruitment
what have been some of your like darkest
days biggest challenges that you really
had to work through and pick yourself up
uh back up from yes i don't think i've
got like a
a particular day or a particular period
that was you know
really really bad and i always think
about it or anything like that but i
think just in general like the first
three to six months of the job obviously
i came in like i mentioned a minute ago
no prior sales experience no recruitment
experience i obviously knew that the job
was hard and knew that obviously you do
get rejection
things go wrong you know people can let
you down but i think
one of the challenges that i definitely
face with and i think it's a lot of
people can probably relate to is that
you know that it's not personal you
don't need to take that rejection
personally and i think
after you know a couple of things go
wrong you know i don't know candidates
might not accept offers or candidates go
elsewhere or they decide recruitment is
actually not for them anymore
i think it can i think it's very easy
for you to basically get down about that
um especially in the first couple of
months um but then you know you do just
have to kind of pick yourself up and go
again you know it isn't personal i think
once it's happened a couple of times you
just get used to it you know you don't
just let it fade you anymore i think
it's just all about
picking yourself up and going again but
i think that is one of the things that
it took me a while to kind of
you know not not go home and think about
it or i could have done this or could i
have done that you know sometimes i mean
obviously there is occasions in the
first year you know you are learning
especially if you've not done this
before you know it is all about training
period but i think you know you you
don't need to go home and beat yourself
up about it you know sometimes things
just don't work out so i'd i'd
definitely say that a challenging point
for me was not taking the rejection
personally um
and there's a lot of rejection yeah yeah
especially on the graduate front as well
you know you change the mind left right
and center um so i do think that is a a
big thing and obviously because the
graduate market you know
it is very fast-paced you deal with a
lot of candidates on a daily basis as
well so you know if one doesn't work out
you know you're on to the next one uh
you know the bad days don't last too
long at all uh you know you could have
one something in the morning go wrong
and then three things go right in the
afternoon so it's just all about having
that mentality really and you know with
the rejection that you receive and it's
it's not personal and you know if you do
it it's obviously you know in your
training period there are learning
curves but i think that's how you
develop as a consultant as well by
things going wrong because if nothing
ever goes wrong then you're not gonna
you're not gonna learn from it really
yeah absolutely no thank you for sharing
that super
super common i guess nath what comes up
for you what have been some of your
biggest challenges at virtus so far that
you've had to overcome and work through
do you think yeah i think i think one
that stands out massively he's obviously
mentioned that i came into the role
probably expecting to do maybe better
than i did initially and the way that
our business model works is you come in
as an associate and it's 16 deals in 16
weeks to get to retcon obviously over
that time you take on more and more of
the process and the idea is that by the
end of that you can sort of fly on your
own and do 360. and that's when your
senior target starts now remember sort
of i joined in the october so it was a
run-up to christmas anyway guys were
dying down a bit getting all my excuses
out early here but it was a bit of a bit
of a quieter period and i think it was
the week before christmas and i had
three things that could have gone in
that would have put me on like eight and
11 i would have been doing all right to
come back in the new year and one
ghosted me one rejected offers one
didn't get offers and i sat there on a
friday sat down with my manager like
jacob and i run thinking i'm on five and
eleven yeah like what's going wrong
we've obviously gone on the christmas
tree and then i've sat there with beer
there the next day got like a two and a
half hour train journey home for
christmas and had three weeks off to
think about it like this is
tough this this is a lot harder than i
maybe thought it was going to be but i
think the best bit of advice that i ever
got given that i used massively in that
situation and i always think about is
whether you think you can or you think
you can't you're probably right and i
think there's a bit of a crossroads
there where i could think you know you
can either pack it in here and you can
say it's not for you or you can give it
a real real good go and come out the
other side of it and obviously
thankfully i think one of the biggest
things here at the vertices obviously
the culture and the leadership and the
guys were able to sort of drag me out of
that turn it around do 16 and 16 and
then i've not really looked back since
i've become a retcon so i always
remember that time as like if i can get
through that i can probably get through
a candidate not not answering the phone
and i use that every day now
yeah no that's awesome that's uh yeah i
really love that that's a great way to
think about things
i guess uh i've really enjoyed asking
this so i'm going to ask you first like
obviously nathan spoke a bit about
something that he keeps top of mind when
things do really
sort of uh when when [ __ ] hits the fan
and you have dropouts and you have loads
of people go through in a certain day
you just have one of those days do you
have like a a sort of go-to ritual that
sort of helps you just like yeah go
again and like forget about it do you
someone that needs to go for a walk or
you just write it down i don't know is
there anything that sort of helps you
just dust it back off
yeah i think i'm inventor i like i like
to voice my problems yeah i'm an
inventor uh i like to voice my problems
you know sit down with you know managers
or anyone in the office just kind of let
it all out and i think you know a
problem shared is a problem half you
know obviously everyone does have bad
days you know it's inevitable in a job
like this but i think if you can share
your frustrations i think that's half
the trouble to be honest and back to
what nate said you know having you know
working with colleagues working with a
team that you're able to do that i think
that's key to be honest and you know
even if you do vent your issues to them
or explain you know what's going wrong
or how your day's been you know they can
even offer advice you know you never
know they might have been in a very
similar situation to you they might have
handled it differently they can give you
like tips and advice but yeah i'd say
definitely for me um i like talking to
people i like voicing my problems and
yeah taking taking that approach really
yeah no i really like i haven't i
actually don't think i've heard that
before problem shared is a problem half
don't really like that yeah that's yeah
i literally i lit so the i recorded uh
one of these episodes with a lady called
hannah before this and that was her so
for her one of the things that she had
to really work on was like not bottling
it up and like then it would just like
build up and then she'd have a really
low day so yeah that's really
interesting that you say that because
then when you speak about it like you
said problem shared problem i really
like that
um
so so nate if i'm gonna ask you a
different question i guess obviously i
know you're not coming up to this year
milestone so i'd love to
hear your thoughts again you could
relate this to previous experience or
alvertus but like what what do you think
you learned in those first
six months uh with vertis and on this
journey so far that maybe you wish you
knew from day one
um i think
the probably the biggest thing is i'd
say recruitment was fairly similar to
what i expected but just amplified so i
knew it was going to be fast paced i
knew there'd be lows and i knew there'd
be highs but i think it's getting into
the role is realizing how fast fast
actually is how low those lows actually
are but then also how high those highs
actually are so probably just uh to
enjoy it all a little bit more i think i
would have actually performed a lot
better i hadn't just taken a bit of the
pressure off myself and just sort of sat
and enjoyed the roller coaster if you
like a little bit more from the start i
think a lot of people come in and they
put too much pressure on themselves from
day one and you can be your own worst
enemy in this job i think i think the
person that's going to make you succeed
and ultimately the only person that can
make you unsuccessful in this job is
yourself um and i think just taking that
pressure off yourself from day one
enjoying it getting stuck in taking a
rejection picking up the phone 50 times
getting a no picking up that 50 first
time and getting that yes that you're
looking for and just enjoying every bit
of that process i think i probably would
have had a much easier and smoother six
months probably would have even
performed a little bit better had it not
been my own worst enemy yeah i know i
think yeah you put that really really
well you know thanks uh sharon and i
guess amber same to you like reflecting
on obviously your first year what did
you
uh yeah what did you learn in those
first six months that you wish you knew
from the start
yeah so i i've always said that
you know you need to be able to ask
questions in a job like this and i don't
i think um i think i'm quite good at
asking questions and asking for advice
asking for help but
what i do wish i kind of did a little
bit more just kind of throw myself in
the deep end a little bit a little bit
quicker and not kind of worry about the
outcome i think sometimes you can
overplay a situation in your head or
overthink it and then like they said you
can be your own worst enemy and you know
if you do just keep picking the phone up
if you do maybe i don't know push back a
little bit or i don't know you know
stand your ground a little bit more or
just whatever it may be just kind of
throwing yourself in the deep end you're
just giving it a go because if it
doesn't work out it doesn't work out but
you know if you spend however long
thinking about it you could have done it
10 times over by the time that you've
come to the decision that you are
actually going to do it so yeah i'd
probably say i just
just deep
just kind of jump in a little bit deeper
yeah just go along with it really
so i guess let's sort of segue into like
getting i'd love to just get both of
your perspectives on
uh i guess not so much like current
market but for people listening to this
they might find this and be considering
a career in recruitment and obviously as
i'm sure both of you will help the
people you work with like that can be
really [ __ ] overwhelming because of
how many recruitment companies there are
right
so i guess nate if i'm going to come to
you on this one like what would you say
is some sort of good quality advice for
people listening who have stumbled
across recruitment had maybe some of
their friends go into it or maybe
discover there and they're now on the
job sites and they're like oh my god
there's so many jobs like how that can
be really overwhelming so like what
would be your advice in terms of like
i'm considering recruitment i'm really
interested in that i'm actually quite
motivated to get into the industry what
would be like this some of the things
that you would share with people to keep
top of mind uh so they can just have a
bit more clarity on like the types of
companies they should be uh looking at
and and those types of things because i
think it can be really overwhelming
yeah well message me our amber first of
all outside joshua
but no i think when you're having that
conversation i think first of all um
it's such a varied industry that it is
actually for a lot of people i think
people have this perception in their
head that oh it's not for me and when
they pick up the phone to us they
realize ah it's not necessarily what i
thought so i think take away one of your
um sort of prerequisites if you like
about what you think the industry is
going to be first of all but i think
once you have decided it's for you and i
think like you say we have a slightly
different take on this because we've got
our ears to the ground a bit more we
speak to graduates day in day out but
having these thoughts and i think one
thing that we always say is a lot of
them are getting into it for the same
reason so they're financially motivated
the businesses that we work with they'll
all offer good training good progression
but i think the the number one thing for
me is the environment that you're going
to go into in the culture and i think
it's probably the one that's overlooked
candidates so so often are swayed by or
you can earn 100 grand in your first
year and you see it on an advert and it
all looks great but like we've said that
first six months is going to be tough
and what will get you through that and
it's what got me through it's what got
amber through it is the environment that
you have around you the manager do you
have the right manager do you have the
right support system in place to get you
through that so i think when it comes
down to it any decent recruitment
business is going to offer you good
earning potential good training good
progression but above all of that
superseding all of that you've got to
look at the environment and is it going
to be a business where when the going
gets tough you want to be there not the
business that's flying you off to ib
through every six months if you hit your
target you've got to look at the
day-to-day are you gonna be and make
sure that you find the environment
that's right for you because we've seen
it so often where people are gonna do
three months in a business and think i'm
terrible at recruitment and you'll go
and find them an environment that's
right for them and they go on to hit
senior they managing their own teams now
and and they thought they weren't good
recruiters because they were in the
wrong environment so i think finding the
right basis to give you the platform to
kick on to be a top recruiter is far
better than any incentive that a
business can sort of run down your neck
yeah yes that's great advice so amber to
build on that then
great advice couldn't agree more and
makes complete sense
i guess amber what would you say then if
like i'm thinking okay nathan yeah i'm
definitely gonna keep that in mind but
like how can i how can i unpack that in
an interview context how can i really
try and extract that and sort of grasp
that um in typically an environment
where these companies are trying to show
off to me why they why they're so great
they might flex a bit they know how many
other companies they're going to be
speaking to and sometimes it can be
really quite hard to sort of grasp that
environment and that platform and what
nathan's speaking about in an interview
context so what would your advice be for
people be to like to give them the best
chance of actually really getting an
authentic look into what that platform
what that environment might actually
look like day to day it's obviously only
a limited amount you can but i think
this is where people can be smart and
intentional with what they do in the
interview uh process
yeah yeah so i think a really good tip
um and this has happened with a couple
of my candidates previously is they've
reached out to people that are actually
working at that company you know they've
been there you know sub a year you know
they might have been there i don't know
six months working towards the next
promotion or something and just reaching
out to them on linkedin you know send
them a connection request and just
messaging them because i think it is
especially if you know if you're a
graduate and you're having i don't know
multiple interviews with multiple
different agencies it can get a little
bit overwhelming and you know face value
you know they are ticking the boxes in
terms of what you're looking for like
they said you know earning potential
progression training and incentives but
i think like you said there is only so
much you can get out of an interview
process but i think a massive tip as
well is just not
not taking the first thing that comes
your way um you know seeing out all of
your options seeing out the processes
and by exploring the market a little bit
you know having multiple interview
stages with multiple businesses you know
going into the office i think you
you will always get a feel for the
environment when you do step foot into
an office you know if you're able to
speak to more members of the team during
that interview process as well and just
asking them about their experience you
know how they found it you know what's
their favorite thing about working at
the company you know what's the biggest
challenge you know is there anything
that you struggle with is there anything
that you know you don't really enjoy
just basically having those open and
honest conversations with people that
haven't been doing the job too long
either because they they can very much
relate to you because that was them you
know six twelve months ago
that's such a great tip
and like that i'm sure like that's also
like extra browning points as well from
like the employers
if they're like oh my god this person's
like being proactive they're asking good
questions like that's that's such a good
tip i think if any of you are listening
and you're in this process right now
yeah reach out to people in that team
that hopefully you can get to the
position where they are and ask some
good quality questions i think that's
such a good um tip amber thanks for
sharing that so on on this topic then i
think there's some useful things here
that people can take so nathan i'll come
back to you
i think when i've spoken to a lot of
people that are early on in their
recruitment career or considering it
again another part of being overwhelmed
is what sector to go into
do you have any advice on that in terms
of like i want to get into recruitment
but i have no [ __ ] clue what type of
sector i want to go into like
like how what's your sort of typical
advice for that because that can be
quite overwhelming for people as well
yeah i actually tell people um maybe not
the advice that you're expecting on that
point but it's almost bottom of the list
for me personally if you're coming in as
a raw grad that's never done it before
if you go into you know any environment
that you go into if they're offering
good training a good progression plan
they're going to take you from knowing
nothing about the industry to being an
expert in that field if they've got the
right training in place to do so the
right progression structure in place to
do so so if you're going into a you know
i speak to graduates all the time and
they'll say like i only want to do tech
and then when you dig a little bit
further and okay great why do you want
to do that
they don't really know it's just
gone on what they're hearing or you know
maybe they know someone that's done it
before but really if you go into any of
these industries provided that you've
got you know enough of an interest to be
able to talk about it on a day to day
no say you're going to tech for example
no one's going to expect you to be a
tech expert you're the recruitment
expert in that scenario so the training
that you get offered will sort of carry
you through the role and then like i say
it comes back to the progression the
environment you actually enjoy being
there can you see yourself being there
long term and i think again that
probably supersedes whatever sector you
were to go for so i actually tell
candidates to think about other things
first fair enough i think sector comes
into it when
say you've got two businesses offering
you and you could just
everything's exactly even and then
you've got one sector that maybe appeals
to you a bit more and maybe favor the
sector but if you go into this idea that
you want to do tech for example but
you've got one tech offer and then this
other business is offering great
progression great environment great
earning potential
don't don't go for the sector because
the other things are far more important
that's normally how i would sort of
position it
fair enough yeah i think i think what's
it from that knife is i i definitely
personally my own experience and
speaking to people i do i would
underline there like you said have
enough of an interest to speak to people
day to day i do feel like that's a
factor because i think because of this
job and the rejection and how hard it is
if you work really hard
to like yeah get to speak to that person
or those things then you speak to that
person and it's just really [ __ ]
boring and you're not curious about it
at all that's going to make it even more
challenging but i get what you're saying
it's like that shouldn't be the leading
indicator into your search it should be
all those other things that you said and
then it's like make sure let's make sure
that you're looking at sectors that you
uh at least have a remote curiosity
about and interested in and then you can
obviously learn but yeah that's good
advice so amber i have to ask you
do young people want to work in the
office
full time
do they want to work from home do they
want to work from the office what what
do young people want amber please tell
us so it does vary um but
as a general percentage-wise what do you
think people must lean to
office based definitely um i think you
know with the environment that
recruitment offers obviously it's quite
a young industry as well it's a social
industry a lot of people enjoy being in
the office you know they like having
that interaction with their colleagues
and it's i found as well because we're
you know when i was going through my
training everything i was in the office
five days a week you know full-time it's
so much easier to ask questions you know
if you're at home you know you have to
message someone are you free for a call
i've just got a really quick question
and something that could have taken 30
seconds you know it might be 15 minutes
because you're waiting for them to i
don't know come off the phone or come
out of a meeting or something but you're
sat in an office with you know all of
your colleagues especially in that
training period i think you can take up
so much more from that um you know we
always say to people like in your first
you know three to six months the job you
know you need to be a sponge you need to
absorb as much information that you can
basically and one way that you can do
that is just by being in the office and
even just hearing you know all the
people on the phone have them having
those conversations you pick up things
and i think you underestimate how much
you actually do pick up just by being in
that environment so i do think you take
a lot more from being in the office five
days a week especially during that
training period and you know we
obviously we have these conversations
with graduates all day every day and and
they like having interaction you know
with the colleagues you know with the
young people you know it's a and
especially like the social side of the
job as well um obviously you know
working from home you know a couple of
days a week once you've undergone you
know your training period yeah that's
absolutely fine but yeah i think most
graduates i would say prefer being in
the office
is it like do they want the choice
like they want the choice to be able to
be like yeah i can work from home
yeah
i would say so yeah the majority you do
get the odd few you know that they're
not bothered whatsoever they're happy to
do anything but i'd say
the overriding majority you know do like
to have the the opportunity you know and
if they did once i don't know work from
home on a thursday or something that the
option is there um but you know we keep
in contact you know with all of our
candidates you know once they have
started you know keep in touch with them
you know how's it all going and a lot of
them do say that they out of choice go
into the office full-time um just
because they enjoy it and also look the
type of people that you're placing let's
be honest unless
you're i don't know you're in a family
that uh are doing all right like you're
you're probably gonna be in some sort of
flat share or like i don't know do you
know i mean like in terms of like the
work from home set up might not be the
best
uh so i think that that's also a big
factor as well
so i guess to carry on this topic and
then i'm gonna ask you a couple more
questions about both your journeys and
we'll finish but obviously i know you
guys cover uh different parts of the uk
so now if you you feel free to we can
break it down but like i'm really
curious to get your thoughts on what
you're seeing on like the base salaries
like i've been speaking to a lot of
recruitment companies
and been having some yeah pretty
interesting conversations that the sort
of base salaries that some entry-level
people are asking for or expecting uh
can be pretty nuts like i've spoke to
some recruitment companies where they've
interviewed people that yeah maybe have
three months experience or no experience
at all and they're going into that
interview asking for a 30 grand base and
i know there's so many factors to this
right inflation and all these types of
things but i guess what what are you
seeing like what's what's become like
um unrealistic in terms of like too much
and unrealistic maybe in terms of like
too low for some recruitment companies
like what what what you find in the
typical base salaries that's actually
realistic the entry level talent are
actually happy with and can yeah are
actually open to and let's just talk
about that for a second because i think
that would be helpful for people
yeah definitely so i think there's
unfortunately for us and it's a
difficulty in a day today for us there's
a lot of nonsense out there about
salaries but at both ends of the scale
and i say this to people on the phones
all day i think some
people think it's like 14 hours a day
change your desk you've got to put your
hand up to go to the toilet and you're
doing that all the minimum wage and then
you've got others that are telling you
that you know any grads can come and
earn 100 grand in their first year so
we've got people bringing us all the
time saying when you ask them sort of
what they're looking for in terms of
earning potential some of them are as
you say going in too low and then some
think that you know when you tell them a
realistic figure that that's slightly
underwhelming because a lot of the
nonsense that's on there but i mean to
put a fear on it i think when i even
when i started
in sort of back in october um i think in
like manchester for example where we do
um sort of like a lot of our business
and i think you know most graduates were
getting sort of 20 and they were happy
with 20. now that's probably low
slightly low or the lower end at least
um
you're seeing graduates getting sort of
22 23 so i'm getting 24 and that's just
fresh graduates that have maybe worked a
bit alongside uni they might have done a
bit of high level sport but no
commercial experience and they're sort
of walking in on 23-24 down in london um
again sort of when i started 23 was the
standard
now it's almost 25 across the board
we've got a public pay sort of 27 for
fresh grads um so it's creeping sort of
up and up and up um but again i think
sort of the constant battle that you're
facing is um a lot of the advertised
salaries against the real salaries and
just sort of trying to pitch a realistic
expectation to graduate somewhere in the
middle of that
yeah no that's good that's that's that's
really
uh really good insight so i appreciate
you showing that that's good good help
for people because i think there is a
lot of nonsense isn't there online so i
think sometimes
p again and that i can imagine it for
both of you the hardest thing is when
you speak to people when they have
certain expectations and then when you
speak to them it's below their
expectations and they're already
like underwhelmed as you said knife and
that's probably not the best position to
start from you'd rather them have lower
expectations and then they're like oh
really like that's that's possible do
you know what i mean so i can see that i
was just curious because yeah i've heard
some some crazy stories of what people
asking for just because of how crazy the
market's been um and people trying to be
competitive so i was just super curious
to find that out um
so i guess let me just i just want to
ask like two more two more questions and
just to wrap this up i guess
um amber what what would like be your
advice um for people um when it comes to
like i guess no actually let me ask you
a different one like how do you how do
you think we can like really move the
needle on like really sort of
incentivizing people to actually choose
recruitment as a career i don't know if
you guys are picking up on more people
wanting to go into it but as you know
typical story is i fell into it i hadn't
knew nothing about it but i just i'm
just so passionate about recruitment
being a career choice and like it can
equip you with so many skills that you
can take into london industries and it
can help you in all areas of your life
but how how do you think that we can
actually really educate people on why
recruitment is such a great career
choice for a lot of reasons
yeah so i think we kind of
i think a lot of people have a lot of
preconceived ideas about
what recruitment is i think it's got a
little bit of a bad name um
a bit of a bad reputation from like you
know years prior um but i do think that
is changing um and we do see you know a
lot of young people you know fresh out
of university and you know we always ask
them the question how have you come
across recruitment you know where have
you got this idea from and
a lot of them just say that you know
it's just from their own research um you
know we always say
yeah
no one ever grows up you know thinking
oh i want to be a recruitment consultant
but i think that stems back to you know
education you know school college
university i just don't think it's very
widely talked about um i know it
definitely wasn't when i was at uni i
know that was a few years ago now but it
definitely wasn't you know i didn't know
anything about it until a couple of
years ago so
i think i think it comes back to
i don't know i think i think there still
is a long way to go in terms of it you
know being more
accessible from an education point of
view i just don't think it's very widely
talked about um but there are a lot of
people that get into it because they
know someone that you know fell into it
you know they might have had a friend or
family or someone like that and i think
it i think a lot of it is word of mouth
um and i think you know it is getting a
much better reputation for itself now
you know one of the daisy you know 11 12
13 hour days you know you don't have to
wear a three-piece suit or anything like
that you know there is there is a lot
there are a lot of good agencies out
there now that you have flexibility you
know you know it is more relaxed it is
more of a you know collaborative team
environment you know you're not being
hit over the head with a kpi stick or
anything like that um but in terms of
like
the question of how do we get more
people you know getting into it i think
it does does go back to you know being
at university college just having you
know those conversations really
awesome and then
nath i'm going to ask you this final
question i feel like i know what you're
going to say but i'm going to ask anyway
again i think this would be really
helpful i think but yeah i love i've
loved recording this with both you
because i think this would be really
helpful for so many people who might be
i don't know maybe a month or so in and
think you know what recruitment is not
for me or actually no maybe i'm not in
the right environment and there's just
been some really good advice here and
also for people that are actively hired
graduates and entry level talent as well
but my question for you nate if i had
this from someone i thought was a great
question
is if you could pick one thing about the
environment um that someone joined that
you feel would allow them
to succeed
what would it be
cultured training incentives
um
i think
well there's a few things you can go for
i think the environment as a whole but i
think if you have to pinpoint it to the
one thing that
maybe for myself look at my own
experience has been
most successful i think it's just
like accessibility so if you look at our
office for example and i mean that in a
few different ways so
how accessible you are to your manager
and what they're actually like with you
i'm very fortunate i work under jacob in
our business he's sort of very good
one-on-one with me we've got individual
training team training group training so
it's that accessibility to um sort of a
good mentor and a good leader but then
also just looking a bit more widely at
your accessibility throughout the
business so the way our office is set up
i've got billionaire shot who's one of
the top builders well the top biller
i've got aaron in earshot who's sort of
second top biller and you've got
accessibility to all these different
people in the business so it's not that
feeling of i've only got jacob to go to
um and he saw my lifeline if he's not
there i'm stuck it's that accessibility
across the wider business that you feel
you can go to anyone um like aaron will
sometimes come to me and say i've
written this cover sheet what you think
about it i'm like that's my sales
director asking my opinion um and it's
just that sort of wider accessibility i
think across the office um that for me
um culture sort of comes down to and i
think that accessibility to management
to train into all these different things
sort of again is probably greater than
any incentive there for a graduate
yes that's a great tip so as i said
honestly thank you so much for for
joining me on this i think this would be
so happening for people and um look
really enjoyed it and and thank you for
for being part of it thank you very much